[Musique]
mes amis de la vie si tous kankan est
astucieux bell bell
la jolie sexy le plus sérieux n'avait
pas joué il s'est dit vouloir devenir
amis
bonjour bonjour toutefois encore jour
fabrice bonjour à tous bon jour à tout
qu'est-ce qu'on fait dit rappelle-moi
fabrice à bien en principe nous devrions
faire le jeu des dessins pour commencer
oui des risées installé d'ailleurs oui
c'est bien ma pauvre tête n'est encore
joué des tours
ça va mieux tout de même et ça va oui
sur la j'ai fait travailler aujourd'hui
dans la grisaille tu vois oui tu as
raison tu as they say dans la grisaille
c'est très joli où ce sont des dessins
d' hervé legrand décès sadad hervé halle
aux grains oui alors il faut que tu les
mettre dans un certaine l'ordre pour
comprendre l'histoire qui est jouée à
dans un ordre logique à la logique oui
tu fais marcher un petit peu
d'intelligence
oui t'aiderai d'ailleurs oui alors fait
très attention à ce que tu dis pas ce
que je vais t'arracher des plumes
blanches
bon alors là nous avons apparemment
c'est quoi ça c'est une gare peut-être
un seul interdit guichets de gare sans
doute je pense je vais voir le deuxième
dessin ni on voit ce sont toujours des
guichets ça c'est toujours une kia il ya
un détail
fabry un détail qui doit être indiqué
l'ordre chronologique est décédé mais
river regarde le troisième qui
comprendra mieux
oui oui l'ordre dans lequel se suivent
les dessins au paddy dont il y en a qui
ressemble à un cow-boy la sagaie t'as vu
oui tu permets que george est un coup
d'oeil
alors ça ça et ça oui je sais par lequel
il faut commencer
c'était simple tu essayais de m'égarer
en fait voilà la réponse
il y avait une horloge sur ce trois
dessins n'est ce pas alors si nous
prenons le dessin sur lequel il est
11h45 c'est-à-dire ce dessin là nous
avons une heure de départ 11h45 les si
nous poursuivons nous avons ici
12h05 - oui d'ici et puis nous avons
ensuite 12h15 à la pendule
ne suis-je pas extrêmement fort
ah là là tu vois ça s'est joué sur une
demi-heure celi et wii et wii ainsi va
la vie
ainsi va la vie est ainsi je vais dans
le jardin et bien voilà c'est parfait
voulais pas te le dire mme avril et
givet ne bute pas encore à nous avons le
point commun maintenant à vous attendent
en tout cas là il arrive pas là il me
voilà j'arrive je suis de moins en moins
rapide mais pour ce qu'ils feraient
fabrice oui nous sommes en place
ailleurs je ne viens pas à pas je ne
viendrai pas fabre et six abribus et
voilà voilà ce qui sépare oui au bois tu
essayes toujours là me fait chuter dans
les jeux et puis après tu m'appelles
parce que tu veux que je vienne c'est
facile
comment ça c'est très facile ça elle
rejoint s'appelait alors le point combat
voilà le point com
alors qu'est-ce que tu es aujourd'hui
toi et bien aujourd'hui moi je te
signale qu'on me trouve dans les
restaurants ah bon oui je fais partie
des repas des déjeuners et des dîners
naturellement je parle aussi bien des
grands pas de mariage de baptême ou de
première communion que des déjeuners
comprend rapidement avant de retourner
au travail tu vois
on peut commander n'importe quoi du
poisson de la viande des glaces
n'importe quoi tu vois je suis moins
toujours là toujours à la fin du repas
et ce qui est curieux peut-être ça va
t'aider un petit peu c'est que si tu
fais le même repas chez toi je ne suis
pas là je n'existe qu'au restaurant tu
vois pas non pas du tout aller coûte
très facile caisse j'écoute est belle
moi je ne te surprendre aide pas à te
connais mon amour de la musique
eh bien je suis une grand à des oeuvres
musicales une symphonie ou pourquoi pas
un opéra ou l oratorio bon bon bon bon
bien sûr j'ai fait aussi partie des
oeuvres légère je ne dédaigne pas les
opérettes les chansons leur enfantine
ronda picotte à la maria tu sais tout ça
te connaît oui je suis également dans
les fanfares les musiques de cirque en
somme dès que vous entendez jouer d'un
instrument
vous pouvez être tranquille je suis là
là là là là là je suis là là là là là je
suis là là là
alors oui alors alors alors c'est clair
je dirai au secours parce que pour
l'instant je ne pouvais rien du tout
pousse moussu oui oui est ce que tu peux
bien mais bon bah moi moi moi je suis
tout petit petit but armand ou on aime
pas au restaurant niño concert moi je
vais encore à l'école et tous les
écoliers me connaissent bien
1 il y en a qui je fais peur ou bien
qu'ils ont de moi et nous pendent montré
un puits en a d'autres par contre alors
là au contraire ils sont très fiers de
me voir arriver ils n'arrêtent pas de me
regarder
il me montra alors par an à leurs amis à
ses vrais enjeux je peux être très
montrait très bon excellent même mais
hélas il m'arrive d'être très très très
mauvais je dirais même plus exécrable
alors tu as compris rien mais alors
aujourd'hui absolument rien
abba pourtant assez ya des jours comme
ça aujourd'hui j'ai fermé qu'est ce que
tu as eu rien alors je résume je ne sais
pas très bien ce que tu mets toi tout
qu'on côtoie dès que tu faisais partie
des repas mais uniquement au restaurant
afin dire par oui à la faire on me
présente à la fin du repas voilà c'est
ça à te présente à la fin du repas je
veux dire si je suis là je suis de la
musique alors c'est plein de petites
choses et non de la musique tu peux
acheter sa toile écoliers mais son petit
carnet fabien et moi ah ça y est oui la
note bbb- notes la mode voilà j'ai déjà
animé par magic va oui tu vas ont trouvé
des notes
oui mais qu'est ce que bell bell va
préparer les siennes mehdi dont j'allais
le dire à fabrice moi même j'aime pas
nous contenter duel de mes affaires
enfin cela plutôt tous les jurys mme
comme je suis quand même lui faire mon
petit bisou comme d'habitude son
territoire et l'avons fait comme s'il
n'existait pas bon on jouera ensemble
d'accords tu vas pouvoir d'accord je
veux au tableau à vous voulez faire des
clans à nous allons en faire tous loin
là où ce mot sur le mois alors alors
alors cette semaine à la rue dont s est
un mot un comme d'habitude un mot un mot
ans il être à oui alors à dormir la
première c'est un mot aux 1 2 3 4
arrière et puis la dernière un e accent
aigu importance accent et bien sûr de
toi oui oui ou non là j'en suis sûr
qu'avec sadeghi oui enfin je me méfie
animal non non ce n'est pas un animal
c'est une fleur est ce que c'est une
fleuve non non ce n'est pas une fleur
non est ce que c'est un arbre ah bah oui
et c'est trop vite quand même y trouve
vite d'un arbre est ce que cette annonce
alors qu'à des fruits oui un arbre cas
des fruits oui est ce que tu veux que je
te donne une petite led supplémentaires
a les seins alors la troisième
oui la troisième lettre c'est un ah ah
ah zut alors n'attendez pas du tout à ça
rabon a à a c'est le piège alors là
c'est pourtant facile un arbre cas des
fruits a qui commencent par oao attend
avec mais ça va parler aux uns comme
internet tient pas est ce que c'est un
oranger mais oui un oranger un oranger
ben oui accent aigu ben oui ça continue
alors d'un oranger accent aigu et action
aigües nous ne l'imaginons pas que ça
pourrait s'écrire père comme bras et
j'ai eu 1 et enfin que c'est compliqué
l'orthographe en orange et on a
heureusement que tout va nous dire des
choses sur les orangers pour te
rattraper parce que leurs barres renonce
à tout expliquer fini je suis pas doué
je suis fait par leur taille mais alors
les arbres je les connais bien ça mail
celui là et qui pousse que que dans le
médian est ce que tu sais que c'est un
arbre extraordinaire parce qu'on utilise
tout ce qu'il produit ses fruits
ses feuilles dont on fait des infusions
ses fleurs avec lesquels on fait de
l'eau de fleur d'oranger et en plus en
plus son bois oui c'est un bois très
très très dur
c'est avec lui qu'on fait les manches
d'outils les plus solides c'est simple
le jour où j'habite près dans le midi je
ferais poussée des oranges et là tu as
raison 1 on ira ensemble dans le midi
c'est d'accord moi je veux bien
d'ailleurs on ira on ira pendant les
vacances et on emmènera bébel quand même
drôlement rabelais tout quant à la wii
allait venir si bien merci
1 oui tu veux pas d'écouter partie des
battus par les arts visuels et la voir à
l'écouter on avale l'écouté
[Musique]
le risque est joué avec moi c'est facile
à musiqueplus à la famille assad aurait
mis sa masse l'adoré salmon famille
façon dont les miens tellement ça va
donner des ailes à la crise et du jeu
avec moi je joue avec toi lors on se
sert toujours des notes de la gamme
elles sont là mais on va faire un peu de
bricolage
oui tu es ses droits oui enfin c'était
même capable de planter un clou sont
écrasés les langes mecquois sentent
écrasés les langes les mélanges bah
écoute préviens moi que tu commences le
jeu les phares oui
l'enjeu c'est exactement ce que je
voulais pertinente écrasé les phalanges
voilà écoute moi ce que j'ai à te
demander n'est vraiment pas difficile
je voudrais simplement que tu m'aides à
réparer un vieux fauteuil débat il est
trop il faut lui couper les pieds tu
sais te servir d'une non au oui oui
regarde la note que je mets la vie c'est
une salle parfaitement suite il faudrait
rembourrés le scier le ciel oui si tu te
dire cet effrayant
le dossier de façon à ce que nous soyons
bien à
6 voilà vrai dire ça bon alors tu feras
sa solidement
oui et je ne voudrais pas que tout
s'effondre sous le poids de la première
personne qui viendrait s'y installer il
faut que ce soit ce temps là c'est dur
un bruit ces défis figurent c'est
difficile attend attend rés oui si l'on
en croit un peu durcies quoi ici temps
restant et il est très fort tu sais moi
je te préviens oui si mon fauteuil n'ai
pas réussi
ce sera pour moi une vraie des patios
wii ware une vraie une vraie une des six
ans alors là attention s'allume la
relation d isolation absolue est fort
alors tu feras ça pour moi oui c'est
d'accord bon dis donc qu'est ce qu'on
fait maintenant de la musique toujours
de la musique baroque band n'osa me à 10
me me tuer si c'est mon petit abri
oui mais tu vas jamais demi et d'un mini
heiva jamais me il alors mis le même et
pilar mimile les mimiques halimi
j'aimais me sait jamais mais a bien fini
et donne à cachan tmh anton alors
les tatamis déjà papa et d'amis de tadla
qui peuplaient la vie majeurs et des
histoires et rzeszow se déchausse pour
les comme juni batterie minois niveau
rappelé
pratiquement réussi et 4 ça me semble
heureux d'arisem amis
oui
à vouloir devenir variés
de wazemmes estime que le foot